People will say, "I'm not
flexible enough to do yoga.
I'm too old to do yoga.
I'm not healthy
enough to do yoga."
But really, if you have a
body and you can breathe,
you can do yoga.
And just by
regulating the breath,
someone can have a
profound experience of yoga
in their very first class.
But that 15 minutes you
spent nourishing yourself
means that when you
go back to your family
or you go back into
your work situation,
you have something to offer.
In this MasterClass
you're getting
something basic
yet very essential
to your understanding
of what yoga is.
I'll be demonstrating
the simplest practices
to more advanced versions
of those practices.
This is a really
wonderful way of breathing
if you're anxious, if you're
feeling emotional tension.
Purse the lips,
making a sound "who."
You may want to add
imagery that you
have a candle in front of you.
You're making it
so gentle, so soft,
that the candle doesn't
flicker or go out.
Life as we know it can
change in an instant.
Three years ago, I had
a serious accident.
I've been using yoga
to restore my body.
First two years was mostly about
learning how to walk again.
I'm witnessing quite a
miraculous restoration.
We may move through some
real storms in our life.
Thank goodness I've had yoga to
find some part of myself that
is unshakable, pristine,
could never be damaged.
That's really the
focus of the practice--
to find the part of ourselves
that is always steady.
I'm Donna Farhi, and
this is my MasterClass.